THAN THE SENATE.
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON RESOURCES IN
VIRAL PROTECTION AND TRANSFER TO
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION TO
ORDER.
WE WILL START OFF AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- TO THE SECOND PART
OF OUR CALENDAR WHICH IS THE
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST.
I HAVE TWELVE LEGISLATIVE
REQUEST BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
I WILL READ THE REQUEST -- WILL
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
AFTERWARDS I WOULD ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO BE BRIEF AND THEN --
IF THE SERGEANTS CAN.
CALL FOLKS I WILL SEVEN BOREDOM
TAKE CARE OF OUR REGULAR
BUSINESS THIS IS ON PAGE FORTY
THREE OF A TODAY'S.
AGENDA INDEED THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION -- I CATEGORY WE HAVE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN MUSEUM A FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND REQUESTS.
WITH THE OCEANS RESOURCES
ENHANCEMENT AND HATCHERY PROGRAM
WE HAVE A THREE POINT.
THREE MILLION ANNUALLY FOR FIVE
YEARS UNDER GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS WE HAVE AND THE
GROUNDING OF ELECTRIC FLY
[inaudible]
WIRES [inaudible]
UNDER.
WHAT WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
FEASIBILITY STUDY IN GLENDALE
FOR THE A RURAL [inaudible]
DO GUY.
GREEN WAY FEASIBILITY STUDY.
WE ALSO HAVE AT THE AURORA SEIKO.
I PARK WATER REVIEW SAID NATURAL
STREAMS RESTORATION THREE POINT.
SEVEN TWO FOUR MILLION WERE --
THAT THE IMPROVEMENTS.
THE ROBINSON PARK RECREATION
CENTER AS REQUEST OF SEVEN POINT
EIGHT AND RENOVATIONS.
INCLUDING THE SWIMMING POOL AND
PULLED HOUSE SOUTH PASADENA
RECYCLABLE GREEN ENERGY PATHWAY
PROJECT.
AS A ONE POINT.
THREE FOUR F. -- REQUEST FOR
INSULATION OF SOLAR ENERGY.
THE ONE AURORA -- STREAM SIDE
WALK DEMONSTRATION PROJECT HAS
REQUEST FOR TWO POINT.
SIX I'M MILLION DOLLARS.
AT THE ONE RURAL WOODLAND LOOP
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT HAS A
THREE POINT. SIX MILLION DOLLAR.
A TRIAL CONCEPT STUDY.
THE GLENDALE HI BERRY AND
COMPLEX OF BRIDGES HAS A FOUR
POINT NINE THREE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
OF PEDESTRIAN PATH.
UNDER CROSSINGS IN THE BURKE
SHIRE AND VELIA POCKET PARKS
HAVE A FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR.
RICK QUEST FOR THE CITY OF
PASADENA.
AND THE OTHER THE TITLE OF
ENERGY WE HAVE THE DELL WORLD
WATER COMPANY FOR MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME IN GENERAL FUND
REQUEST.
THOSE ARE THE ROOF -- THE FINAL.
THE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS REQUEST
PEOPLE THE PUBLIC WITH THE LIKE
TO COMMENT ON THAT.
WE'LL HEAR YOUR TESTIMONY PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD ALL THOSE
MATTERS OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- LET'S
CALL THE ROLL AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
MY COUNTY HERE ALLEN'S REQUIRE.
MONEY.
STERN.
AREN'T WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL
HAVE. TO WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN HAS BEEN REQUESTED TO
REMOVE FROM THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR WILL HEAR THAT.
MATTER SEPARATELY.
I'LL THE CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS IS AS SET FORTH
IN THE CHEN THERE.
WERE.
ITEMS NUMBER FOUR FIVE AND SIX
ITEMS.
NINE ITEMS ELEVEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN ITEM TWENTY ITEM TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I
AM TWENTY SIX I AM.
TWENTY EIGHT I AM TWENTY EIGHT A
I AM TWENTY EIGHT P. I AM TWENTY
EIGHT C..
IS THERE SUCH A MOTIO.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
MINING.
THIS IS.
NOT THE SESSION [inaudible]
YES.
I WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE
[inaudible]
TO SPEAK.
ON ANY THE THE ITEMS IN MOTION
NUMBER.
ONE CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I CASTING HI.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
RUNNING.
OKAY WILL KEEP UP THE ROLL OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR ITEMS.
ISSUES NUMBER ONE TWO AND THREE
ISSUE SEVEN AND EIGHT ISSUES IN.
TEN ISSUE [inaudible]
FOURTEEN ISSUE. SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN
ISSUE TWENTY ONE ISSUE TWENTY
FIVE ISSUE.
TWENTY SEVEN ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT
D. N. TWENTY EIGHT HE IS JUST
SUCH A MOTION.
THIS MOTION BY SENATE MCGUIRE.
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND ON
THE ITEMS IN MOTION NUMBER.
TWO CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THIS
CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MINING.
NINE OKAY WILL CLEAR.
THAT HIS VISION VOTES WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN NOWLET'S TURN.
TO ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
FIFTEEN THIS IS.
THE WILDFIRE PREVENTION RECOVERY
LEGISLATION TIMBER HARVEST PLAN
EXEMPTION UNDER.
AS SET FORTH IN SENATE BILL.
NINE OH ONE AND WELCOME FISH AND
WILDLIFE [inaudible]
DEPARTMENT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHUCK BOTTOM
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
ITEM FIFTEEN RELATES TO A
SPECIFIC BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
FROM OUR DEPARTMENT.
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU LAST
DISCUSSED BACK IN MARCH PERHAPS
EARLY APRIL.
IT WAS HELD OPEN AT THAT TIME.
HERE ARE THE ESSENTIAL
INGREDIENTS.
OUR DEPARTMENT PROPOSES FIFTEEN
POSITIONS [inaudible]
AND A TOTAL OF THREE MILLION
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR FOR SKEW
YOUR NINETEEN TWENTY OF WHICH
ONE MILLION. FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND IS GENERAL FUND
AND TWO MILLION IS.
TIMBER REGULATION IS FROM THE
TIMBER REGULATION AND FAR AS RE.
HER IS RESTORATION FUND EXCUSE
ME.
THOSE FIFTEEN POSITIONS. ELEVEN
ARE RELATED TO THE TIMBER FUND
AND FOR OUR THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND.
WHEN WE ENGAGED ON THIS TOPIC
LAST TIME I TOLD YOU THAT IN MY
VIEW THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
WAS FOR A VERY SPECIFIC PURPOSE?
POST CATASTROPHIC.
FOR ARE THE LEGISLATURE --
PASSED SENATE BILL NINE A ONE
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THAT BILL
AND IS NOW A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO DEALING WITH
CATASTROPHIC FIRE.
WITHIN THAT COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH OUR TASKS FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT.
OUR DEPARTMENT SERVES IN AN
ADVISORY ROLE TO CAL FIRE AS
WELL AS THE BOARD OF FORESTRY.
DEALING WITH THE PROPOSED
INCREASE USE OF NOTICE
EXEMPTIONS.
I MANAGE THE CATASTROPHIC FIRE
RISK.
THAT COULD PROVOKE ADDITIONAL
WORK FOR OUR DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS
ADVISING ON MANAGING TEMPORARY
ROADS OR STREAM CROSSINGS.
HELPING CAL FIRE HOST ACTIVITIES
IN COMPLIANCE MONITORING AND
REPORTING OF THOSE INSPECTIONS.
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY IS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS.
ARE SENATE BILL NINE OH ONE LEAN
HEAVILY ON OUR DEPARTMENTS
DIRECT ENGAGEMENT WITH THEIR
AGENCY.
OR POST PROJECT MONITORING AND
PRE PROJECT CONSULTATION.
SENATE BILL NINE A ONE INCREASES
OUR WORKLOAD IT CAME WITH NO
FUNDING.
SINCE THIS BUDGET CHANGED.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT YOU
HAVE AN ANTICIPATION THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE MANY MORE OF
THESE TIMBER HARVEST PLANS.
FASTRACK VENDORS NINE A ONE
COMING FORWARD AND THE DESIRE TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
GUARD AGAINST.
SEGREGATION TO THE TO THE AT THE
HABITAT BUT ALSO GET THE WORK
THE DESIRED WORK DONE TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TIMBER.
THAT'S A TWENTY AIMS TO TWENTY
M. GO FAST AND DO MORE -- THE
THING IS THIS IS THIS GOING TO
DO IT.
GIVEN THE THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
OR THE ANTICIPATION THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT THE TIMBER
HARVESTS PLAN CITY COULD BE --
FILE OR IS IT GOING TO BE A
DELAY I GUESS THAT'S THE CONCERN.
YES IT WILL HELP US DO IT
BECAUSE IN THE ABSENCE OF THIS
BUT TO CHANGE PROPOSAL WE WILL
HAVE NO ADDITIONAL.
THIS PROPOSAL ADDS FIFTEEN STAFF.
IT WE CAN PUT SPECIFICALLY ONTO
THE ASSIGNMENT.
OF ACHIEVING BOTH OF THOSE
OBJECTIVES FIRST.
GETTING THE WORK DONE
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO REDUCE OUR FIRE
RISK SECOND.
DOING IT IN A MANNER THAT'S MOST
PROTECTIVE TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
CALIFORNIA SHOWS IT'S NOT AN
EITHER OR PROPOSITION.
THE OPERATIVE WORD IS A IN.
YOU CAN REDUCE THE FIRE RISK AND
DO RIGHT BY OUR BY MIDDLE
CONCERNED SIMULTANEOUSLY.
THIS PROPOSAL ALLOWS US THE
STAFF TO INVEST DIRECTLY INTO
THAT DIALOGUE WITH HOW FAR.
AND HOW IS IT GONE WITH.
SLAVE KAISER HAPPENED TIMBER
HARVEST LANCERS BEEN THAT YOU'VE
WORKED WITH THE A CAL FIRE IN
THE DIFFERENT AFFECTED AREAS
AREAS HOW HAS THAT --
COORDINATION WITH THIS ESTATE
AGENCIES GONE BETTER.
CERTAINLY IN MY TENURE IT'S HAD
ITS UPS AND DOWNS.
BUT IN MY PERSPECTIVE AFTER
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO WHICH IS THE
OTHER THING THAT WAS DEBATED
WHEN WE LAST MET AND MARCH.
OUR AGENCIES ARE CO LOCATED.
OUR CO ASSIGNED TO A COMMON
PURPOSE.
AND WHILE THE DATA CAN REFLECT
DIFFERENT TRENDS I THINK OVERALL --
DATA COMING OUT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO SHOWS.
IN MANY REGARDS WERE FINDING
PERMIT EFFICIENCIES.
IS IT A WORK IN PROGRESS AND WE
DO BETTER ABSOLUTELY.
BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK
BACKWARDS OVER THE LAST SAY FIVE
TO SIX YEARS YOU'LL FIND DATA
THAT SHOWS.
EFFICIENCY TREND LINESARE UP
NOT CATEGORICALLY ACROSS THE
BOARD DOWN.
OKAY A SEMI WHERE YOU HAVE A
QUESTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
IN A DO APPRECIATE AT THE
DIRECTOR AND FOCUSING ON THAT I
I JUST WANT TO HONE IN ON A
COUPLE OF ITEMS AND I I
APPRECIATE YOU GET THIS
INFORMATION.
TODAY SO -- JUST WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO WALK THROUGH SOME ITEMS AND
THEN.
HOW IT RELATES TO OTHERS CALLED
THE TIMBER TAX RIGHT SELF
IMPOSED -- IN IN -- WALK THROUGH
IT.
I THINK THEY GET THE CONCERN
THAT WAS ADVANCED LAST TIME AND
I KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
YOU'VE ALSO BEEN FOCUSING ON IS.
DONE. ONE OF THE INTENTIONS.
OF ADVANCING THE TIMBER TAX.
AT WHICH IS INDUSTRY IMPOSED IS
TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE THE REVIEW
TIME.
I'M IN SO -- I I THINK WHAT
YOU'VE SEEN.
IS IN YOUR WORKING THIS OUT
STILL BUT AT THE A TRAIN
POTENTIALLY OF OF AN INCREASE
REVIEW TIME.
I'M AND I JUST WANNA GET BETTER
HANDLING ON THAT.
IT SO I'M JUST GONNA WALK
THROUGH AN INVESTOR DIRECTOR FOR
SO IT WORKS FOR YOU JUST IF I'M
CORRECT IN MY ASSUMPTIONS.
STE.
SO TYPICALLY WHAT THIS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN USED FOR IS THAT GREEN
TIMBER [inaudible]
HISTORICALLY.
INSTANCE FIRES HAVE COME IN.
YOU ARE SEEN ENHANCE.
OUR WORKLOAD.
BASE OFF OF FIRES IN IN
HARVESTING THOSE. FOR SENATE
IMPACTED BY FIRE.
SO THAT IS THAT CORRECT
[inaudible]
SO.
THAT IS AT A DRIVING FORCE
SOMEWHERE SEEN [inaudible]
AN INMATE.
ENHANCE TIME TO BE A REVIEW
PLANS YOU CAN JUST WALK US
THROUGH THAT.
I MISS A COUPLE THINGS FIRST
SENATOR FIRST.
I'M APPRECIATIVE OF THE STATE'S
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR TIMBER
INDUSTRIES.
BUT FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP YOU
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO AND OUR
TIMBER PROGRAM THAT ARE.
TO WOULD HAVE BEEN DOWN IT ZERO
STAFF.
AND IT'S THAT COLLABORATION THAT
HAS ALLOWED US TO REBUILD THE
PROGRAM.
BUT I WOULD SAY IN MY MIND
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO AND THE WORK
WE DO WONDER THAT.
WELL PERHAPS RELATED IS SEPARATE
FROM THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
TODAY.
LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO FROM AN THE NEXT
THING I'D SAY IS IT'S MORE THAN
OUR DEPARTMENT IT'S STATE WATER
BOARD IT'S CAL FIRE AND CAL FOR
HAS NOT BEEN ENGAGED IN THE TO
HEARINGS WE'VE HAD ON OUR
DEPARTMENTS PROPOSAL.
THESE METRIC.
SINCE WE LAST MET I THINK I
MENTIONED I WOULD DO THREE
THINGS.
AND I'M REMISS ON ONE OF THEM.
pHARD TO HAVE THE AGENCIES REPORT.
ON FOURTEEN NINETY TWO TO YOU
BEFORE OUR NEXT ENGAGEMENT.
AN AGENCY IS WORKING TO GET THAT
RIGHT YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD NEW
LEADERSHIP COME AND WE HAVE NEW
INFUSION OF ENERGY INTO THEIR
TIMBER PROGRAM.
AND I THINK THEY'RE TAKING A
CAREFUL REVIEW OF THE NEXT
REPORT.
THE SECOND THING I SAID I
BELIEVE I WOULD TAKE CARE OF IS
PROVIDING YOU ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FUNDS
STATEMENT.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT AS
FINANCES SUGGESTED TO YOU A MOCK
UP OF THE FUNDS STATEMENT OF
THIS NUMBER.
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE MY STAFF HAVE
OFFERED YOUR OFFICE A SNAPSHOT.
OF SOME OF THE METRICS FROM THE
NOT YET RELEASED BUT UPCOMING
RELEASE OF THE TIMBER REPORT.
SO WHAT I SEE HERE A COUPLE
THINGS.
IN SOME OF THE FACTORS I'VE HAD
EXPLAINED TO ME YOU'RE RIGHT
ABOUT THE SHIFT FROM A FOCUS OF
GREEN TIMBER AND GREEN TREE
HARVESTING. TO MORE OF THE TREE
MORTALITY WORK I THINK THAT'S AN
UNDERLYING FACTOR WILL WE SEE IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IS.
COMPANIES SHIFTING OVER TO
DEALING WITH TREE METALLIC.
IN USING EXEMPTIONS.
RATHER THAN PROCESSING AS MANY
T. H. PLEASE.
ANOTHER THING I'VE SEEN IS.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD NEW -- ANIMAL
SPECIES LISTED UNDER RELEVANT
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
AND I THINK THAT THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO SOME OF THE
REVIEW PROCESS ON THE T. H. P.
FRONT.
I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS CAL FIRES HAD
SOME VACANCIES -- IN PARTICULAR
IN THE SANTA ROSA AND READING
OFFICE WHICH ARE KIND OF THE HUB.
THE T. H. P. REVIEW --
ENTERPRISE THAT WE STOOD UP
BETWEEN OUR AGENCIES.
LET ME JUST CHECK MY LOOK.
IN BEFORE YOU GO TOO FAR SO --
IN THAT WASN'T WHEN MY QUESTION
SO IS THAT.
JUST WANTED TO GET A CLEAR FIVE
FROM EASTON OVER SO.
THOSE VACANCIES AS CRITICAL
VACANCIES ARE WITHIN ONE
DEPARTMENT OR ARE WE LOOKING AT
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS I
UNDERSTAND HE'S CAL FAR OKAY BUT
I'M DESCRIBING A SERIES OF
THINGS WHICH I THINK IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS.
OUR WHAT IS UNDERLYING SOME OF
THE TREND LINES YOU'RE
POTENTIALLY HEARING OR SEEING
WHICH IS AN REVIEW OF DHT.
YEAH THE REVIEW TIME MIGHTBE
CHANGING.
OR THE SIZE OF THE AMOUNT OF
ACRES INVOLVED IN THE PLANS
APPEARS TO BE DECREASING RIGHT.
AND I THINK THERE ARE REASONS
FOR THOSE TRENDS ONE REASON AS
PEOPLE APPEAR TO BE.
PURSUING LAST HARVEST UNDER THE
T. H. P..
AND MORE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
NOTICE OF EXEMPTIONS RELATED TO
THE FARMERS.
ANOTHER REASON FOR A POTENTIAL
SLIGHT INCREASE IN THE REVIEW
TIME.
IS.
THE ADDITIONAL LISTING OF
SPECIES WHICH REQUIRES MORE
CONSULTATION MORE PAPERWORK.
AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY.
A MOMENTARY LOSS IN CRITICAL
STAFFING AT CAL FIRE IN THE
CENTER ROSE IN REDDING OFFICE.
BUT I ALSO THINK YOU CAN LOOK AT
THE DATA AND THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN REPORT.
AND YOU CAN FIND TREND LINES
THAT ARE SHOWING POSITIVE IF YOU
THINK JUST ABOUT OUR DEPARTMENTS.
PROCESSING WE ACTUALLY THINK ARE
LAKE INSTREAM BAT ALTERATION
WORKLOAD.
HAS INCREASED BUT THE PERMITTING
TIMELINE TO DEAL WITH IT IS
SHRINKING.
SO MY MY VIEW IS WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE DATA YOU CAN FIND SOME
TREND LINES WHICH ARE.
OF CONCERN THAT WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND I THINK YOU CAN FIND
SOME TREND LINES THE SHOW THE
FUNDING IS PRODUCING PERMIT
EFFICIENT [inaudible]
AGAIN JUST.
I KNOW WHERE WE ARE ALL TRYING
TO ABSORB THIS -- AT THIS POINT --
IN IN A LITTLE BIT OF A FIRE
HOUSE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
AM READING CORRECTLY
[inaudible]
SO.
ON THE TV FRONT.
REVIEW TO PROVE 6% PURE CHEESE
PEAS COVERING 32% CURE RATE.
THE BIGGEST DRIVER FOR THAT
[inaudible]
IS.
GOING THROUGH THE EXEMPTION
PROCESS.
YOU'RE NOT CHECK IN THAT JUST
EXPLAIN IF YOU DON'T MIND TO
MEET.
THE THAT THAT PROCESS I THE
EXPEDITED SIDE [inaudible]
SO.
YOU HAVE BEEN GIVEN A SNAPSHOT
METRIC WHICH I GET YOU TO SAID
REVIEW APPROVE 6% FEWER TICKETS
PLEASE.
WHY?
YOU ARE T. H. BEES ARE BEING
SUBMITTED.
BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE ARE PURSUING
A FOCUS ON THE EXEMPTION WORK.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF THAT
DATA SAID THEN.
IN WALKED ME THROUGH THEN
BECAUSE THEN WE SEEN.
I'M JUST DOING THE MATH HERE BUT
I THINK I I'M MONTHS LONGER
THOUGH TO BE A TO DO.
THE TEACHER PEAS -- BUT THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLANS HOW MUCH MY
PIECES AND AGAIN NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO BE DO I GOTCHA I I'M
LITERALLY JUST.
SINCE IT IMPACTS OBVIOUSLY THE
NORTH COAST AND MISTER DIRECTOR
EVEN ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN THIS
WHICH I'M GRATEFUL FOR IS JUST
TRYING TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF IF WE'RE
LOOKING IN A MONTH LONGER IN
REGARD TO TEACH BEES.
YOUR CHEESE REASON ACRES COMING
THROUGH IS TRYING TO RECONCILE
THAT GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES OR
THREE EXAMPLES OF WHY THE REVIEW
TIME APPEARS TO INCREASE OKAY BY
THE FIRST.
YOU DO A TYPICALLY YOU DO A PRE
HARVEST INSPECTION.
IT RAN LIKE CRAZY THE HEAD
SERIES ABOUT A DISTRICT RIVER
EVENTS DURING THIS TIME FRAME
PEOPLE COULDN'T GET OUT
[inaudible]
SECOND.
IN SOME OF THESE AREAS WHERE WE
NEED TO DO THE PRE HARVEST
INSPECTION WHICH IS A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM IS JUST NOT MY
DEPARTMENT.
NO.
PREVENTED YOU FROM GETTING OUT
EARLIER YOU HAD TO GET OUT LATER.
THIRD AS I MENTIONED WE'VE HAD
SOME ADDITIONAL SPECIES LISTINGS.
WHICH THEMSELVES CAN CAUSE
ANOTHER LAYER REVIEW TO MAKE
SURE YOU'RE DOING.
YOUR PROCESSING WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES
CONSISTENTLY.
BUT THESE ARE FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO ISSUES AND WHILE I REALIZE
YOU DON'T HAVE THE MOST CURRENT
POOR.
IN MY PERSONAL VIEW THESE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NEXT REPORT
I CAN COMMIT [inaudible] TO
COMING AND DISCUSSING THAT
REPORT WHEN AGENCY RELEASES IT.
I SEE ASEPARATION BETWEEN THESE
QUESTIONS.
ENDED LATE.
AND SENATE BILL NINE OH ONE
FUNDING.
WHICH IS ASKING OUR DEPARTMENT
GO DO NEW WORK AROUND CAT AS FAR
AS TRAFFIC PIRATES.
BROUGH THE EXEMPTIONS AND THAT'S
ALL OUR PROPOSAL IS SEEKING IT
WHAT I WAS TAKING A LEASE THAT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT YOU ARE WORKING ON BEING TO
GET IT DONE AND WHAT.
OUR UNDERSTANDING LEASE ARE MADE
OUT TO SPEAK FOR MYSELF IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO SEE THAT
BECAUSE WHILE THEY MAY BE TWO
SEPARATE FUND SOURCES AND
INITIATIVES.
IT ALL IS SOMEWHAT RELATED SO I
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY -- THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE IN REGARD TO
THE DIGITAL THIRTY DAYS IS
WEATHER RELATED AND STAFFING.
IN IN THAT SO EVERY SOARING IN
THE REPORT YOU ANTICIPATE THE IS
AS IT'S BEEN A GRADUAL TREND
FROM ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY AS A BEEN A
TWELVE MONTH -- OR IS THIS
SOMETHING IN ALL OF THE TO THE
CHAIR AND THIS LED TO BE RAGING
DISS TO BUILD HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY SINCE.
TAKING IN THE GAME IS COMING ON
THE INDUSTRY SIDE OF JUST.
WHERE WE'RE AT ON THAT BUT I I'M
JUST WONDERING IF YOU WANTED? TO
COVER THAT MISTER DIRECTOR.
AB ONE SECOND.
LOOK I I DO THINK THAT THE THE
T. H. P. REVIEW TIME.
UNDER THE FOUR YEARS I THINK
IT'S BEEN A FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
HAS SHRUNK AND THEN GONE UP MOST
RECENTLY IT'S PLATEAUED AND IT
MAY ACTUALLY GO UP AGAIN WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE COP COMING REPORT.
AND THAT'S OF CONCERN.
WE SHOULD A PRETTY OPEN
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
BUT I'M NOT THE CONTROLLER OF
THE REPORT.
AGENCY IS THE CONTROLLER OF THE
REPORT.
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL ABOUT SENATE
BILL. NINE ONE FOR CATASTROPHIC
FIREMEN.
ANY ITEMS YOU'D LIKE TO BE A
CONCERN.
THANKS BRIAN CASH FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES IN C. LIKE THE
DIRECTOR SAID WE HAVE NEW
LEADERSHIP FOR FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO AT THE AGENCY AND THEY ARE
REVIEWING THE REPORT RIGHT NOW
AND THEY WILL BE.
IN THERE DOING A DEEP DIVE INTO
ACTUALLY EACH DEPARTMET HOW
MUCH FUNDING EACH DEPARTMENT HAS
WHAT THEY'RE DOING FOR WITH AB
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO AND TRYING
TO FIND EFFICIENCIES.
SO UNDER THAT NEW LEADERSHIP
THERE'S GOING TO BE.
I WOULDN'T SAY MISSION BASED
REVIEW BUT SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
WHERE WE'RE REALLY TAKING DOWN
AND TRYING TO FIND EFFICIENCIES
AND MAK THIS IS.
MAKE THIS IS A FASHION AS
POSSIBLE.
IN INTO WHEN YOU ANTICIPATE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BE A
RECEIVE A COPY OF THAT REPORT.
WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON IT AS
QUICKLY AS HE CAN -- I I WOULD
SAY WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH.
CONSIDER SOME OF THE SNAPSHOTS I
THINK WE SHOULD.
OUR STAFF SHARED WITH YOUR STAFF
INCLUDE.
THE LIKELY METRICS THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY SHIFT BACK TO A GREATER
NUMBER OF T. H. HE'S.
IN THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PERIOD
WHICH MEANS A CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN THE AREA.
OF LAND UNDER THE T. H. IS.
THAT ALSO SAY.
SOME REASONS POTENTIALLY FOR THE
REVIEW TIME BUMPING UP.
ALSO INCLUDE.
SOME OF THE T. H. BEES WERE
CONVERSION T. AGENCIES WHICH
TEND TO BE PRETTY CONTROVERSY.
THE REQUIREMENT BY MIDDLE IMPACT
REPORT CERTIFIED BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S INVOLVED.
AND I THINK WE'VE HAD INSTANCES
IN THIS LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WHERE THE T. H. P. IS THAT
ORIGINALLY FILED BY THE
SUBMITTER.
HAVE BEEN WITHDRAWN BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO GO FOCUS ON THE DROUGHT
MORTALITY EXEMPTIONS.
AND THEN WHEN THEY COME BACK TO
THE TIMBER PLAN THEY'VE GOT
SIGNIFICANT REVISIONS BECAUSE
TIME IS PAST WHAT WHAT I'LL SAY
IS A AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTOR LOOK.
NOT AT ALL TRYING.
TO DO AND I GOT YOUR WHATSOEVER
SIMPLY TRYING TO BE A FOLLOW UP
ON AN ITEM THAT WE SAID WE WOULD.
SO YOU ARE CORRECT IN THE PAGE
AND A HALF OF A SNAPSHOT.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS WE HAVE.
ITEMS IN.
WE'RE UNABLE TO DO A DEEP DIVE
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE WE ARE THE
FORMER IMPORTANT FRONT OF US.
NUMBER ONE THERE'S DISCUSSION
ABOUT TRANSITION FROM GREEN TREE
HARVESTING -- TO EXEMPTIONS AND
THEN THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION --
POINTS IN REGARDS.
TO IN INCREASE AGAIN NEEDING
BEER HAVE A FULL REPORT TO BE A
TO GIVE FULL CONTEXT.
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO BE A TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION HERE
TODAY -- I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO SOME HEARING.
AT THIS CASH AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON THIS WITHIN
THE NEXT THIRTY FORTY FIVE DAYS
TO BE FAIR RIGHT.
I'M RANGING THERE -- AND I I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO GO OFF
LINE ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY FOR LOOKING INTO AN
ADDITIONAL MONTH.
RIGHT INCREASE FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THOSE
FACTORS ARE -- AND BE ABLE TO
ASSIST AND BRING THAT DOWN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TELLING US TO HAVE A COMMON.
WHEN WE RESERVE AT RETAILERS
ADELIA WHEN WE REVIEWED THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU BACK
IN JANUARY WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS?
ON THE NINE A ONE SIDE ALRIGHT
THIS IS ITEM ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTEEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
LET'S OPEN UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT --
WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THEN SB
NINE A ONE FORTY AB FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO OR WHATEVER.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
[inaudible]
BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- RICH
CORDON THE PRESIDENCY OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY IS ASIAN.
THE FORESTRY ASSOCIATION WAS
ACTIVE IN.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO BACK
AGREED. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A
TAX ON LUMBER.
IN ORDER TO ADD TO S. SEE.
AN INCREASE IN IN THE TIME FRAME
THAT IT TAKES.
PROCESSING REDUCING THE
PROCESSING TIME FOR TIMBER
HARVEST PLANTS.
AB.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT TWO THINGS
FIRST ABOUT THIS SPECIFIC BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL -- THE DIRECTOR
IS ASKING FOR FUNDS. TO HIRE
STAFF TO MONITOR EXEMPTIONS TO
TIMBER HARVEST PLANTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT EXEMPTIONS TO
TIMBER HARVEST PLAN SHOULD BE
MONITORED.
I WE WANT THAT KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHETHER -- FIFTEEN POSITION IS
CORRECT WE DON'T.
KNOW.
HIS JUDGMENT IN TANDEM A GUY
WILL ACCEPT THAT.
WHAT WE DO HAVE CONCERN ABOUT IS
POTENTIALLY THE SOURCE OF THESE
FUNDS COMING OUT OF THE TIMBER
TAX?
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE REPORT.
IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS SINCE WE HAD
A REPORT OF FROM -- THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE ACTIVITY
UNDER THE YET THE TIMBRE OF
REGULATION AND FORCE RESTORATION
PROGRAM.
WITHOUT THAT REPORT AS WE ONLY
HAVE ANECDOTAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHETHER ACTUALLY ACHIEVING THE
GOALS ORIGINALLY IN.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO OF REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES TO
PROCESS THE TIMBER HARVEST PLAN.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE ALSO DON'T
KNOW THE STATUS OF THE FUND.
IN OUR PROJECTIONS ARE THAT THE
FUND IS HEADED TOWARDS A DEFICIT.
IN A ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FROM
THE FUND AT THIS POINT.
COULD MAKE THAT DEFICIT.
OCCUR FASTER.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET AND SO THEY
PROBABLY FUNDING TO TO PAY FOR
THESE POSITIONS THIS YEAR.
BUT WE ARE HEADING TO A POSITION
WHERE THERE WILL BE SOME
BRINKMANSHIP AROUND HOW WE
MANAGE OUR TIMBER HARVEST PLANTS.
THE OF EVALUATION AND MONITORING
OF EXEMPTIONS.
AND DO THAT IN A WAY THAT.
HOLDS TRUE TO WHAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN PASSING AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS MAKAYLA MAY HAVE A
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES WE DID -- BEFORE YOU A
FULL TWO MONTHS AGO.
RAISING THESE CONCERNS WE SHOT
MY COMPANY MY CLAN EXCUSE ME
SHARES THE CONCERNS THAT.
MISTER GORDON -- INDICATED I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE TO YOU.
AND BY NO MEANS IS THIS A
CRITICISM OF THE CURRENT IT THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION NOR.
DFW BUT THERE MIGHT BE A
RATIONALE FOR HOLDING UP THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT.
ALTHOUGH IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
DONE OBVIOUSLY BY THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT I DON'T THINK A NEW
ADMINISTRATION AS A
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STILL LACKING.
AND THE ISSUE THAT WE WERE
RAISED WITH YOU TWO MONTHS AGO
NOW WAS IS HOW CAN THE
LEGISLATURE DO AN ADEQUATE
REVIEW.
AND MAKE A FIRM DETERMINATION WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN THIS DATA.
IN TWO PLUS YEARS AND WHETHER
THERE'S UPS AND DOWNS IN REVIEW
OR ANYTHING ELSE WE KNOW CLEARLY.
THAT STAFF CONTINUES TO INCREASE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE NUMBER OF T. H. P.'S
GENERALLY ARE ON A DOWNWARD
SLOPE AND YET REVIEWS ARE WELL
ABOVE.
WHAT THEY USED TO BE?
AND SO I DON'T KNOW HOW THE
LEGISLATURE AT THIS POINT CAN
MAKE A DETERMINATION ON THIS
BUDGET REQUEST WITHOUT A FULLER
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT DATA THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'LL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAY S..
JUST SO EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME
PAGE IN THE ISSUE BEFORE US.
HERE'S ONE POINT FOUR EIGHT
THREE MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
THIS YEAR.
IN TWO MILLION IN THE TIMBER
REGULATION AND FOREST.
RESTORATION FUND IN [inaudible]
TWENTY NINETEEN RIGHT.
IT SEEMS TO BE THE SPLIT I'M.
I GUESS THE QUESTION FOR
RESOURCES REFER THE DEPARTMENT
IS [inaudible]
WE'VE GOT.
WORK IT'S GOING TO BE DONE ON
THE EXEMPTION THAT SEEMS TO BE
POPULAR GIVEN SB NINE OWN NINE A
ONE AND THEN THE REGULAR --
TIMBER HARVEST -- PLAN C.
EXPEDITED TIMBER HARVEST PLANS
TO RECORD A GOOD.
ONE EDUCATE ME ON IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT SPLIT THAT WERE USING.
ARE WE USING MONEY FROM THIS.
HARVEST FUN -- A TIMBER HARVEST
FUND THAT'S BEEN ACCUMULATED TO
TO PROCESS THE NORMAL TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS THAT ARE
[inaudible]
GREEN.
HARVESTING FIRST TO SEE
EXEMPTION WHICH IS A REMEDIAL I
GUESS YOU WOULD SAY REMOVAL OF
DEAD.
TREES I ASSUME THAT THAT STILL.
MARKET APOLOGY.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE CRITICAL WHEN
BUT CAN YOU SHINE SOME LIGHT ON
THAT TOUR WERE USING APPROPRIATE?
BALANCE OF GENERAL FUND AND THE
M..
RESTORATION FUNDS MONEY.
I SEE MY COLLEAGUE OF FINANCE
RAISING HIS HAND.
A THIRD DRIVER PART OF MY
ANTARCTICA OF FIRST STARTED IT
SO WONDERING THE PROPOSAL WE
ANALYZED -- WHAT OF THE
ACTIVITIES ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE A A BEFOREHAND YOU STATUE
WAS IDENTIFIED WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF THE FUNDS ARE --
AND SO THOSE ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE NOT CONSISTENT WITH THAT WE
USE THE GENERAL FUND FOR WE MADE
SURE TO TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THAT LANGUAGE WHICH IDENTIFIES.
THE USE OF THE TEMPERATURE. TO
SOMEONE BASED ON THAT YOU WOULD
THINK THAT THAT.
THE MAJORITY HAS TWO MILLION. TO
ONE POINT FOUR EIGHT THREE SO
SOMEBODY DID IT BREAK DOWN BUT
THE MAJORITY OF THE REMOVAL OF
PRODUCT.
WOULD BE.
IN LINE WITH THAT WHAT YOU
EXPECT WOULD BE A BENEFICIAL USE
UNDER TIM TIMBER HARVEST PLAN.
AND THEN THE OTHER THE OTHER
BALANCE WOULD BE OTHER CONCERNS
[inaudible]
FOR MITIGATION FIRE.
PROTECTION PREVENTION YEAH THE
DATA.
DIRECTOR HERE'S HOW I WOULD%
ANSWER JUST SPEAKING PERSONALLY.
THE PROPOSAL RELIES ON TO FUNDS
SOURCES.
IN MY JUDGMENT EACH FUND SOURCES
APPROPRIATE.
YOU ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THE
RATIO.
I THINK THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
I'D ALSO SAY THE POSITIONS ARE A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN POSITIONS
THEMSELVES LET. ELEVEN ARE ON
THE TIMBER FUND FOR ON GENERAL
FUND [inaudible]
THAT.
I THINK REASSURES ARE FAIR
QUESTIONS AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE
SEEN OFTEN DISCUSSED DURING THE
BUDGET PROCESS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WHY ARE YOU HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION LEAVE MY LAST COMMENT I
I THINK THAT THE CHALLENGES THIS
RIGHT? ONE WE ARE DELAYED IN
SEEN THE REPORT -- BUT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST IS IN FRONT OF US
ASKING FOR THE MAJORITY THESE
POSITIONS TO BE ABLE TO COME
FROM THE TEMPLE FUND.
AND WE'RE SEEING A SNAPSHOT AT
SNAPSHOT SHOWS ABOUT A MONTH
INCREASE.
IN THE APPROVAL OF TIMBER
HARVESTING.
SO WE HAVE A SELF IMPOSED TIMBER
TAX. ONE OF THE GOALS NOT THE
ONLY ONE ONE OF THE GOALS WAS A
DRIVE THAT.
THE TIMELINE FOR APPROVAL TEACH
BEES.
SO NUMBER.
ONE WE ARE TWENTY FOUR MONTHS IN
ARREARS IN REGARDS TO THE REPORT.
NUMBER TWO THE MAJORITY THAT THE
POSITIONS ARE BEING CHARGED THE
TIMBER FUND.
AND THEN AT NUMBER.
THREE I HAVE SOME CHALLENGES OF
IS IT REALLY.
THE RATIO IS THAT RIGHT RATIO
BECAUSE NO ONE CAN SEE.
SO I THINK WHAT WERE IN A
POSITION HERE TODAY I HAVE.
TRUST AND THEN WE HAVE TO VERIFY
AFTER WE TAKE A VOTE.
SHARE WITH YOU IT'S FRUSTRATING.
I THAT WERE IN THE POSITION AND
I WOULD SAY THAT MISTER CHAIR.
IF THIS IS IN FRONT OF US NEXT
YEAR -- IN WERE UNABLE DECIPHER
I WOULD FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT.
DOING IT FOR A SECOND.
YEAR IN A ROW.
SOME CONCERNS WITH THAT IN CASH
WOULD LIKE TO SIT DOWN.
DEFINITELY A TO BE ABLE TO GO
OVER THAT PROPOSAL THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE BRINGING FOR AS FAR AS
THE FOURTH.
OKAY THERE WE HAVE IT IS OUR
MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION STAFF.
POINT MADE PLEASE CALL RURAL
[inaudible]
CASKEY HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
THE MATTERS.
APPROVED FOR ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON MOTION
NUMBER ONE WHICH WAS.
ITEMS FOUR FIVE AND SIX ITEM
NINE ITEM ELEVEN TWELVE THIRTEEN
ITEM TWENTY ITEM TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I AM
TWENTY SIX I AM. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT A. TWENTY EIGHT B.
AND TWENTY EIGHT C. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS.
THE CURRENT VOTE COUNT IS. THREE
ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
DOWNS.
CLOSE ROTEL THE VOTE THEM.
MATTERS ARE PROOF FIVE ZERO ON
MOTION NUMBER TWO WHICH IS ITEMS
ONE TWO AND THREE ITEM SEVEN AND
EIGHT ITEMS.
ITEM TEN ITEM FOURTEEN ITEM
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN ITEM TWENTY ONE I AM
TWENTY FIVE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT T. N. T..
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
STERN.
OKAY CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTERS.
MATTERSIR PROOF.
FOUR ZERO AND WE ARE ADJOURNED
UNTIL [inaudible]
TOMORROW.
AT ONE THIRTY ONE THIRTY IT
MIGHT BE.
CONSIDERABLY LONGER AND IT WAS
TODAY
[inaudible]
I